in this video i will teach you how to
multiply any number with 11 in less than
5 seconds
let us take an example 23 multiplied by
the trick here is very simple write the
first digit 2 2 plus 3 is 5 and then
write the last digit as it is that is 3
here is the answer 23 multiplied by 11
is 253
let us take a slightly tricky example
now 567 multiplied by 11
for this write the first digit five
five plus six is eleven
we shall write eleven like this one your
and one over five like this six plus
seven is thirteen and seven is written
as it is five plus one is six one plus
one is two and three and seven are
written as it is 6 2 3 7 this is our
answer
here's one more example why don't you
try solving this and let us know the
answer in the comment section in the
next video we will learn how to multiply
any number with 12 13 14 and so on in
less than 5 seconds
don't forget to subscribe to our channel